tuesday night was an amazing night
didn't it feel good it was good to feel
good after months of endless dreary
negativity failure incompetence chaos
crisis afghanistan inflation supply
chain lockdowns mandates lectures
climate catastrophe the world's about to
end america's racist you're racist
everyone's racist and honestly whether
you're a democrat or a republican
however you feel about any of the
candidates that ran in virginia you
can't help but watch this and smile
i'm telling you
that what you are looking at
is the
american
dream
the american dream
when my father came to this country
august 11th of 1963
he came at the height of the civil
rights movement from jamaica
he came and i said to him but it was
such a bad time for us why did you come
and he said because america was where
the jobs and the opportunities were
the american dream yes that's what i
believe in i know it's what you believe
in it's why i was so proud to become a
citizen a few months ago wasn't it
refreshing to see leaders elected who
just love america and are proud to say
so and wasn't it refreshing to see
leaders elected who were positive and
practical none of this weird woke
ideology that moralizing and patronizing
and virtue signaling and dividing the
hateful intolerance where those who
disagree with you aren't just wrong
they're evil they're nazis they're
enemies of the state domestic terrorists
remember those sanctimonious signs love
trump's hate
well last week it was trump voters plus
a good few biden voters who trumped the
hate
coming from the democrats and on tuesday
night we saw why
on day one we're gonna jump start our
jobs and reinvigorate this economy so it
lifts up all virginians
we're gonna get this economy moving
again growing four hundred thousand new
jobs
fostering ten thousand startup
businesses friends virginia will be open
for business i used to say as we were on
the trail
hold on virginia
help is on the way the cavalry has
arrived there is no
time to waste
our kids can't wait we work in real
people time not government time exactly
that's what people want positive
practical policy not mean-spirited
ideological dogma real solutions to
real-life problems that's what people
voted for and by the way that's what
people voted for in 2016 too a
problem-solving business guy offering
practical plans
that's the lesson from last week for
republicans in 2022 and 24 be positive
focus on what you're going to do
specifically to help people in the
future do it with a smile on your face
positive and practical it may sound
trite but it's a deep truth
about how you win elections
amazingly the democrats seem to have
learned the exact opposite lesson from
last week's results they're doubling
down on hate and division this was
former head of the dnc and failed
presidential candidate howard dean
racism still works in virginia that's
what you got from it
from an election where the black vote
for republicans went up and the black
vote for democrats went down where
according to some exit polls the gop
actually won a majority of the latino
vote that's racism jameel hill this
country simply loves white supremacy
white supremacy yeah the white
supremacist republicans who elected the
first black woman as lieutenant governor
the first latinos attorney general
meanwhile those great champions of
racial justice the democrats managed to
lose black delegates representing black
districts
the left's knee-jerk racial demagoguery
is incredibly corrosive of our social
fabric
just listen to how they talk
this is about the fact that a good chunk
of voters out there are okay with white
supremacy let's call a thing a thing
actually scratch that they are more than
okay this isn't a party that's just
another political party that disagrees
with us on tax policy that at this point
they're dangerous they're dangerous to
our national security because stoking
that kind of soft white nationalism
eventually leads to the hardcore stuff
that msnbc host who let's remember has a
history of vicious bigotry and
homophobia knows all about hardcore
racism she provides a platform for it on
her show he was one of our guests
talking about winsome seas immigrant
ex-marine black republican woman
there is a black mouth moving but a
white idea through the running on the
runway of the tongue of a figure who
justifies and legitimates of the white
supremacist practices
have you ever heard anything so
disgusting so divisive so fundamentally
at odds with everything america stands
for and if democrats aren't calling
everyone who doesn't vote for them
racist well they're just dumb and
gullible his former clinton campaign
spokesperson jennifer palmieri trotting
out the deplorable smear because you
know it worked so well the last time
things like crt those things take hold
in uh with voters in the face of
inaction when there is dysfunction right
and and that is when people can fall
prey to
you know like sort of race-based um
arguments like that
oh they fall prey to race-based
arguments to they those dumb republican
rubes race-based arguments that's the
entire democrat playbook because biden
himself put it
if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump and you
ain't black
it's also revolting the democrats
demented and despicable strategy of
racializing everything one of the few
willing to reflect honestly on all this
was bill clinton's former strategist
james carville
looking at these results uh your party
uh what went wrong
but wrong was just stupid wokeness
defund the police
luna cities take abraham lincoln's name
off of schools some of these people need
to go to a woke detox center
yeah not just some of them all of them
because they are poisoning our society
look at the crazed self-righteous zeal
of these ideologues as they turn
legitimate political disagreement into
hostility and harassment hounding
kirsten cinema in a bathroom stall
holding up joe manchin in a parking
garage i mean what is this who behaves
like this
normal decent people don't
but this is who the democrats seem to
have become they never stop going on
about trump's divisiveness and
inhumanity well on this as on everything
else they are guilty of the exact same
thing they accuse everyone else of the
democrats have become the party of hate
and division and last week's election
was a massive repudiation of everything
they now stand for hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else